the U.S Commerce Secretary ended a trip
to China with a stop at the theme park
described as the happiest place on Earth
Disneyland in Shanghai Gina Raymondo is
the fourth high-ranking U.S Diplomat to
visit in recent months tasked with
injecting positivity into the
increasingly fraught bilateral
relationship the U.S Chinese
relationship is too consequential we
can't we can't drift to a place of
greater conflict it's not good for the
US it's not good for China it's not good
for the world
so we have to commit ourselves to take
some action Redondo met Premier Lee
Chung who said economic ties with the
ballast of sino-us relations but that
relationship is under increasing
pressure
Raymondo says U.S firms have told her
China has become uninvestable and too
risky pointing to recent raids by
Chinese Security Forces on foreign
companies
she's renewed calls for the Chinese
government to level the playing field
for foreign firms her visit also comes
weeks after the U.S issued another round
of investment curbs targeting Chinese
technology firms trust in the US's
intention to negotiate in good faith is
reached absolute zero
we've heard American officials kind of
say all the right things about seeking
cooperation with China but then send I
think at best very mixed messages by
continuing to pressure Chinese companies
to put sanctions on on Chinese entities
officials here have criticized American
efforts to block China's access to
Advanced semiconductors a topic raimondo
said was not open for debate however
during a meeting with Commerce Minister
Wang Wun Tao the two sides did agree to
form what they called an information
exchange to discuss export controls as
well as a new working group focused on
Commercial issues
environment
but further disagreements plagued the
four days of discussions China says the
US is over generalizing so-called
National Security to contain China's
economic growth something Raymondo
denies we're not targeting China we're
targeting certain Behavior the Chinese
government is defending its treatment of
U.S firms saying it's working to improve
Market access for the 70 000 that
operate here expectations for this visit
were low though the opening of new
communication channels is seen as a win
for business and a positive step towards
stabilizing ties
and it's hoped another step towards a
meeting between President stir Biden and
Xi Jinping at the Apex Summit later this
year Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera